never I've never seen anything that I
pray to God I never see it again it's
what seasoned medical professionals
called a bloody massacre comparing this
crime scene to a horror movie brand new
body camera captures the unsettling
aftermath when a high schooler gave
birth in an emergency room bathroom
allegedly killing her newborn son I've
never ever
seen a reaction
like that girl on January 27th 19 year
old Alexi Treviso was admitted to an
Artesia New Mexico emergency room after
complaining of back pain her newborn son
was later found stuffed inside a trash
can in a bloody bathroom she had just
used the high school senior was charged
with first degree murder and tampering
with evidence before her graduation
discovered that
a Deadpool neck long crime Network first
brought you the chilling body camera
video last month when medical
professionals confronted Treviso about
the baby see I told you about this
I just asked you baby to tell me the
troubles
it was not crying already
what did you do to it now we're hearing
from medical staff who uncovered the
gruesome scene after she gave birth when
I went in there it was a glory bloody
massacre body camera video shows police
officers speaking with medical staff who
worked the Nitra Visa was admitted into
the ER she said
she said she was kind of way
when the whole thing happened Hospital
surveillance video shows Treviso leave
her patient room at 1 38 a.m waddling
toward the bathroom while clutching her
back traviso remains in the bathroom for
19 minutes as multiple people check on
her I knocked on the door and I said are
you okay and she said yes I'm fine I'm
just having a hard time going to the
bathroom is what she replied
so I was like okay at some point I went
and kind of checked on or knocked on the
doors and if she needed anything she
didn't I just said she didn't need
anything did you hear anything I didn't
I didn't hear anything plus the toilet
flush yes after a while I started
hearing so I probably checked on her two
to three times I'm not exactly sure and
then I just kept hearing paper towel
dispenser
and flushing in like the water running
and I knocked in did she need anything
denied anything in it and eventually it
got to a point where
I said you need to come out and I asked
the uh the clerk to get the key to
unlock the door because obviously she
locked the door to go to the restroom
and whenever I finally we finally had
the key to unlock it she opened it and
just kind of walked out
did she say anything and she was just
looking kind of straight past me and
went back to the room surveillance video
captures that moment as Treviso leaves
the bathroom and heads back to the
patient room it was then that hospital
staff got a look at the bloody bathroom
for the first time and all I saw was
like blood everywhere like on the walls
on the toilet it just looked like a
horror film police speak to multiple
people who saw the bathroom describing
fresh Blood on the walls floor and near
the toilet the toilets are here where
you're at and then the seats right here
it was like up this way blood splattered
right
and you're in your line of work what
would cause that kind of splatter
something that got pulled
out like if you rip something in blood
just went it was like
like once you see the the photo you'll
see what I'm talking about it's just
it's like you say like rip like
something went like that yeah like if
you when you
or if you cut some cut something you go
like you swing your hand and blood just
splatters okay so that's how it looks oh
so this is fresh to you yes
yes that was fresh you could even smell
it we didn't know what this Blood was
from we were we were a little concerned
that maybe she had you know known that
we were gonna figure it out and that she
might have harmed herself or something
in the restroom so the dog wanted to go
check her but
obviously that wasn't the case unclear
as to what had happened other nursing
Staff Care for Treviso believing she had
a miscarriage oh she came out of the
restroom uh there was
a trail of blood from the bathroom back
to her room
uh we went to a room I went to get her
undressed the doctor came in
explained to her that she had a
miscarriage her mom had a back and forth
about it the doctor said she had a
miscarriage
okay she said it like it seems
essentially like I'm not sure the exact
words
it seems that you've
suffered from a miscarriage which didn't
seem totally abnormal
mascara just before they're very bloody
right and so um
all down her legs and then there was
like blood in the bathroom everywhere so
where exactly was the blood and how much
uh it was a good amount it was like on
the floor minutes later cleaning staff
arrived to wash up the bathroom
was called and
to go clean the patient's bathroom and
ER
around I can't remind you two o'clock or
so I think it was the time I'm not too
sure
so when I went in there it was a glory
bloody massacre Mist could you describe
it if possible uh yeah there was blood
everywhere uh
there was blood on the floor on the wall
you remember which one
um the one behind the toilet and then
the one on the side right here
you know there's that one um where the
toilet sets back of the Hat yeah and
then on the side uh where the call
button is yeah okay
and on the floor everywhere after
cleaning the entire bathroom Twice The
Cleaner grabbed the trash bag to toss it
away that's when she discovered the
newborn baby when I went to go through
the trash I felt that when I picked up
the trash and I looked in it there
wasn't you know there was trash in it I
knew that it was you feel like when I
picked it up it was some weight so I
thought it was the trash bags because we
put the trash bags on the bottom
and so I started getting the trash out
and then when I did that I seen that
there was a baby in there and that's
when I um I freaked out and I called uh
uh Lori and HD or the nurses up front
and uh because there was a baby in the
trash
and if they when I looked at it I the
baby was wrapped up like in a you know
like in the bottom of the trash can and
with trash on top of in a trash bag
and so how did you did you see it like
as soon as you picked it up uh no after
I picked up the trash bag that was uh on
top you know okay so they were throwing
the trash out when I picked that up to
change it
that's when I noticed that there was uh
finessing the baby you'd like to
describe the babies yeah he was about
that big he had hair
and um
he was like
purplishment but still not
like
pink you know I don't know how to
describe it you know he was like he
wasn't bruised or nothing like that and
he was like purple pink pink skin type
color the cleaner then calls for a nurse
who describes the disturbing moment the
infant was discovered and then when I
picked it up that's when I noticed it
even more because all I saw was black
and purple but once we picked it up like
the bag suctioned to his face and that's
when I yelled for my charger nurse which
was HT
and I told him
um hey she put her baby in the trash can
so
um I handed the baby to him
and he took off to the trauma room and
opened up the bag and then that's when
we went and got Dr Vasquez police then
here from the nurse in charge who says
it was clear early on that the newborn
was dead I go in the bathroom and she
goes
something's in the trash can I'm like I
looked in there there's a cleanliner I'm
like what are you talking about she was
pick it up and pick it I could feel the
weight
I knew then we had a serious problem I
immediately took I just grabbed the
trash can and went right across the hall
and there's a trauma too I pulled the
liner was pulled out but there was
another trash bag in there in the bottom
but it was all kind of it was rolled up
so I had to tear it apart and then of
course I saw the baby in there so I
pulled the baby out got him on the bed
took for signs of Life there was
absolutely no life whatsoever
um I immediately came out of there after
I did that went into the room where she
was performing she was performing the
vaginal exam and I immediately told her
you had to come out now and she came out
and we went into Toronto and she
reassessed the baby at that time between
me and Chris and her we determined you
know there was no
reason for us to begin any Lifesaver the
baby was completely gone another nurse
recalls the same moments and could you
tell if the baby was alive or
[Music]
they fast look alive
but also I think the time had passed and
she left the
the bathroom and it being in the bag you
know it was just how long do you think
that was
you know 15 minutes I don't know we
brought the baby up we called the doctor
obviously out of the room from her exam
and uh we came in kind of
doc assess the baby and you know
basically determine it was not viable to
completely work the baby and all that so
that nurse tells officers he believes
Treviso knew she was pregnant and
wanting to hide it from medical staff it
seemed like we were being just deceived
from the beginning but that that's just
my my take on it it seemed like she was
very manipulative with us and it was at
least what it seemed like to me she
didn't want you to discover you know
that she was pregnant and she wore
really baggy clothing
um
yeah she she would just she wouldn't sit
still for you I'm sure she was very
uncomfortable too but yeah she she
wouldn't allow you to do it it seemed
like she'd been trying to hide this
pregnancy from her mother from some for
some time so if you pray if you know
you're pregnant you're not going to
continue taking birth control episodes
but if you're trying to hide it you
might start getting weight loss
medications that's kind of what it
seemed like in my head other staff
describe the lengths Treviso allegedly
went to to keep her pregnancy and birth
a secret the umbilical core looked like
an animal had tore it apart
like you know have you ever eaten string
cheese and you know when you twist it
that's how the bottom of the Bell cord
looked and it I just remember it caught
my eye and I was like God
that's like this this chick really
ripped this thing apart after this
medical staff called the police and
alert Treviso about their Discovery I'm
sorry about this but in terms of
delivering
um a baby and it looked like you tried
to hide it we do have to have the police
involved
and nothing was crying
came out with nothing and then I went in
there to talk to the to the patient and
then um asked her why was the baby
in the trash can what did she say
she said that it just came out of her
and she didn't know what to do and I
said um
did your baby take at least one breath
when it first happened or did it
to take at least one breath or was it
not breathing and she kind of looked at
me in the face and the eyes and she was
like what can I tell you and I said tell
me why and
set up
so I've been having this bad abdominal
pain she said and we came here to the ER
and when they brought me back here to
this room I felt like I needed to go
poop
she said and I asked if I could go to
the bathroom she said and so when they
said yeah that I could go to the
bathroom
she said when I sat on the toilet she
said it just all fell out
and she said but when I had it in my
arms it wasn't breathing it wasn't
moving
and so
of course you want to be very very
judgmental at that time and you have to
bite your tongue sometimes but
you know my first reaction was like I
wanted to say hey well then why wouldn't
you call us for help but I didn't I so
um she said so I just
he wasn't moving he wasn't breathing
so I just placed him in there nurses who
spoke with Treviso after the baby was
discovered say she never asked about him
instead they say she was more concerned
that she would get in trouble with her
mother
much number one
I was really surprised not one person
asked me about the baby if it was alive
if it was dead if it was a boy it was a
girl no one asked me anything
no she didn't ask the only thing she
started doing was crying and started
talking about she didn't know what to do
not one
I've never seen in my I mean I've
delivered
multiple babies and I've seen multiple
miscarriages and I've never seen a
reaction like that
and um
I I don't even know what to say about
that I've never seen anything like it
mine how would you describe their
reaction I think
um it was there was no emotion except
for herself
and she really wasn't even crying tears
she was just
and then one thing she was upset about
was that I think she was going to be in
trouble with her mother she didn't say
anything about what had happened she was
just essentially worried that she was
just gonna get in trouble so that's what
I mean were those the questions she was
asking like so what's going to happen to
me
I like that kind of thing she ever asked
about the baby
not once she essentially was scared she
was worried that she was gonna get in
trouble
she did have a back and forth with her
mother that was just about like
they had said
oh the mom was upset because
she had had sex and hadn't told her
so they were going back and forth on
that and then she was just denying it
which was
out of the
was a really deniable at that point in
time right so the patient was not having
sex at this point to her mom yeah she
was trying to state that she was still a
virgin after she came in from the
bathroom
others believe Treviso knew she was up
to no good
she definitely knew what she was doing
or what was doing was wrong because the
way she was talking to me you know just
stating you know I didn't realize I was
pregnant and you know but I'm taking the
birth you know so I mean she was
panicked but you know I didn't see her
being in a state of mind where she did
not know what she was doing multiple
hospital staff members say the incident
is not one they will soon forget when
there's like one or two things in the
waste basket I usually pick it up take
it out but I didn't that night and then
like I'd be kicking myself from this
because I feel like
you know if I would have just tooken it
out I would have seen it well no one ex
no one prepares for that type of thing
you know what I mean most people don't
act like that so don't blame yourself
for it yeah because it's not a natural
thing to do
it's just hard because I'm a mother I'm
a grandmother
and I've never I've dealed with death
before but never like this right you
know like it was horrible I'm just gonna
tell you this I've never ever
seen a reaction
like that girl
I am
I don't even know what to say about it
there was Zero emotion
um
I I just I don't know what to say I've
never seen anything like it I've seen
women that are only married or not
married but um pregnant for six weeks
and they lose that baby and they're a
mess
you know what I mean that girl went into
that bathroom made no sounds
at all and the baby came out of her
and had
I I don't even know how
she functioned that way
to do what she did and
with no emotion I've never seen anything
like it
and it was a it was a pretty good size
baby pretty good size it looked term to
me yeah me too I mean it was true I
can't tell you that was but the only
thing that upsets me the most is
I understand she was scared and I think
her mother and had a big Dynamic on her
and I I understand that I mean I think
her mother was probably pretty
controlling I don't know that I'm just
speculation
um but she gave me no chance
to say that baby I had no chance and
that's not what I do my job is to save
lives and I had no chance on that baby
she gave me no chance
and we are a facility that you can drop
the baby off no questions asked you
don't I don't you can just leave the
baby and go I I have no I don't care you
know as long as you bring the baby to a
safe we are one of those type of
hospitals so it's hard to Fathom what
was going on in your mind
I I don't know I've never I've never
seen anything I pray to God I never see
it again a jury trial date for Treviso
has been set for October 2nd if
convicted on the top count of
first-degree murder she could face life
in prison reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie